les sondages qui sont faits en janvier
généralement annonce qui va se passer
c'est à dire si je prends ces en janvier
fin décembre début janvier de nicolas
sarkozy passe devant ségolène royal il
est effectivement élu début cinq ans
plus tard tous d'accord s'il vous est
donné battu et je le redis pour son se
passe des choses dans la campagne et on
l'a vu la dernière fois effectivement
pour jean luc mélenchon il passe en cinq
semaines il passe de -2 10% à presque 20
donc il se passe des choses la campagne
sert à quelque chose et il ya aussi des
événements on a eu cet exemple avec avec
le wii avec fillon mais là c'était
comment dirais-je un choc mais c'est
plus de parquet national financier si
vous voulez qu'ils échouent et que la
politisation des procès dans tous les
médias
français vous avez donc donc
effectivement c'est il va se passer des
choses on a quand même des rapports de
force assez important leur juste pour la
question qui nous intéresse tout le
monde c'est à voir est ce que on est
certain que
les manuels macron sera reconduit on ne
l'est pas preneur dont toute simple
c'est tout simplement c'est un président
sortant pour l'instant il n'est pas
encore descendu dans l'arène ça va pas
être facile pour lui de se déclarer et à
ce moment là il va concentrer non
seulement les attaques de céder ses
concurrents mais surtout beaucoup de
français on se dire est ce que je veux
vraiment le gard en reprendre pour cinq
ans et là ça devient compliqué parce
qu'il ya une base très solide ce que
j'appelle le bloc éditeurs peu près à
25% qui ne l'a pas abandonné qu'il a
même renforcé tout au long du
quinquennat mais il essaie un président
qui est malgré tout minoritaires et dans
un second tour il peut y avoir
effectivement de fortes de fort taux
d'abstention l'ipea voix du candidat
éliminé peut y avoir 6 à regroupement
autour pour l'instant bois plutôt autres
valérie pécresse ou de marine le pen les
choses donc les chiffres effectivement
d'intentions de vote pour le second tour
sont à prendre avec des pincettes
notamment parce que ce paysage politique
ne ressemble pas du tout à ce qu'il
était au trophée
[Musique]